hey David is there any real merit to
ultimate fighting and boxing you didn't
really talk about that big fight that
took place in Las Vegas when you were in
Las Vegas the Ultimate Fighting
Championship fight what do you think
about it so yeah I wasn't actually in
Las Vegas that when the fight took place
this was khabib khabib nurmagomedov
right Conor McGregor yes and that was a
big fight on Saturday October 6th 6th in
Las Vegas I left in the morning though
my flight left at 10:00 a.m. and the
fight was at probably 10 p.m. I don't
know exactly what it was 10 p.m. Eastern
anyway so listen it's so I don't know
that I'm the right person to say whether
there's a merit to Ultimate Fighting and
boxing what I can tell you is the
following
I couldn't care less about people
beating each other up and I have never
watched any of this stuff except if I
was out with friends and they wanted to
watch it and I would just hang out but
does that mean that there is no skill
involved and this of course not of
course there is these are boxing I sort
of maybe can say less about but with
ultimate fighting you are talking about
athletes who train in very particular
and high-level ways very fine-tuned ways
their body is a tool it is a it is a
machine that they want to be as
fine-tuned as possible for this diet is
a component there's psychological
components there is merit to this stuff
do i watch this no I don't care about it
but do I write it off as having no merit
whatsoever I can't do that it would be
wrong for me to do that whether it's
sort of a great thing for society to
make a huge deal out of people men or
women there's women's Ultimate Fighting
now beating each other up I don't know
it doesn't seem like it well I think
it's interesting how mixed martial arts
has evolved over the past 20 years or so
yeah because now we have a better sense
of what a comprehensive fighting style
looks like like in the early days of the
UFC they had some sumo wrestler guy go
up against the karate guy and I had a
jujitsu guy go up against I don't know
like a judo person and we'd see kind of
what won out
and now everything is morphed into you
have to be able to fight standing up yes
I could fight on the ground and what I
thought was interesting about this last
fight in Vegas was you had someone with
one specialty in grappling versus
someone with another specialty in
striking Shore and you know it's just
one one scenario but you can kind of see
what works better what doesn't work and
you know the implications for that maybe
we can learn how to defend ourselves
better I don't know it's tough to say
because you don't want people getting
hurt you don't want brain damage and all
there are other negative things that
come along with it but green as a
species maybe it is important for us to
know about this stuff I guess my
position is I'm against the
glorification of violence and violence
as a sport
but I do believe that there is a lot
that goes into the preparation for doing
MMA that has more broadly applicable
lessons and information or something
like that the one thing I think is it
fair I mean I'm just speaking completely
off the top of my head because I'm
clueless about this stuff as people can
probably tell is it fair to say that if
you're a good boxer that doesn't
necessarily make you a person who has
the skills for really being set up to
like defend yourself properly in a
street fight where is the MMA skills
because you may end up getting knocked
down to the ground or whatever like the
auxin is a much more narrow set of
skills than what MMA requires MMA is a
lot more practical because yeah a lot of
street fights end up on the ground and
you have to be able to defend yourself
not only standing up but on the ground
too I mean an average person against
trained boxer in a street fight it's
pretty obvious the boxers gonna win but
if you take any run in the mill MMA
person versus a run in the middle boxer
hmm I favor the MMA guy because you can
just you know tackle them and that's
being yes I mean I think is assuming
that you're in a street fight situation
I think if you put an MMA guy with a
boxing guy in the ring and you tell them
the rules are boxing rules the boxer
wins if yeah but an MMA woman and a
female boxer in the Octagon and say the
rules our MMA rules I think the MMA
fighter probably wins every time but the
thing is that MMA rules are a lot closer
to an actual
like there are very few exceptions to
that like you can't like you know I go I
don't think you could pull hair and that
sort of off-limits stuff but it's very
similar to what you would encounter on
the street how much was it for
pay-per-view for this fight do you know
was it is it all your books is it that
much no Wow Wow
yes see I just I could never get myself
to care enough to pay pay that unless
like I don't know maybe if I knew one of
the people fighting but even then I
don't think I want to see them get
getting beat up right if it's somebody I
care about
see yeah horrible anyway tell me where
I'm wrong I know people will write in
including with links to Joe Rogan videos
explaining to me why I don't know
anything about this and I admit I know
very little about it